herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute ich war letztens auch in
sachen verlegten ihr kennt mich ja ich
mag gerne sachen über verrückte dinge
verrückte dinge können zum beispiel sein
coca cola gadget oder riesen sneakers
oder was auch immer aber ich bin über
eine waffe gestoßen dass ich mir okay
das gibt es wirklich und zwar habe ich
von einem currywurst energy drink gehört
und jetzt leute habe ich tatsächlich von
der firma ein paket bekommen hier ist
und ich habe das gefühl da ist mehr als
nur ein energie bringen vielleicht etwas
laut story wir packen das ganze erstmal
aus und sollte ihr kennt mich ja ich
packe natürlich meine pakete nur mit
vermerk aus weil ihr kennt mich ich bin
mächtig so das paket ihr jetzt deutlich
ausgebaut also ich glaube da ist einfach
für übertrieben viel dachte okay babbel
schon mal sehr gut
ok also erstmal jede menge barrett die
kamerafrau hinter der kamera
bedenklich ihr müsst wissen die firma
fehr stellt heißt arena grings wir haben
auch mit vielen fußball mannschaften bei
spielen wir hier einmal eine ein liter
ein liter dose fc bayern energy drink
what the heck okay natürlich ein low
energy drink von bvb macht dann auch
okay leute jetzt kommen wir irgendwie
richtigen die ich eigentlich angefahren
popcorn limonade ohne koffein und taurin
also ausnahmsweise mal kein energie
bringen da kann ich vielleicht noch
heute nacht ein auge zukriegen darauf
ich sehr gespannt wie direct verrückt
weiter und zwar bubblegum style limonade
ich möchte gerne anmerken lässt dass ihr
charakter ist ist dann ist die firma
einfach gefragt paycheck die mir das
zeug vielleicht damit sich die betreuer
haben sie getan
kleine lose nfl american cola so noch
mit eur bisschen auf beute falls ihr
euch an dass coca cola video
ich habe ein bisschen schiff das ding
ist nämlich ausgebeutet man merkt auch
wenn man drauf drückt gestörtes bedruckt
drauf vielleicht hätte man ja immer wenn
ich das okay leute da ist der einzig
wahre grund dafür hier leute ist der
höhe von jerry buss energy drink ich bin
sehr gespannt wie kann sowas
funktioniert
die haben wir dann noch mal zwei größen
von bvb energy drink okay es war
tatsächlich auch schon so leute fangen
wir an mit den vereinen grings also will
ich bin kein großer fußballfan aber so
das prinzip kennt ihr glaube ich es gibt
glaube ich auch sogar youtuber die show
nancy greene frau aufgebracht haben man
packt einfach den namen drauf aber drin
ist glaube ich glaube ich ein normaler
ring
so sieht es ein bisschen aus richtigen
ganz normaler energieträger für richtig
vorgeplant und habe mich ihr glaube
hingestellt hat auch die farbe von einem
stinknormalen energy drink schmeckt ab
jetzt nach bvb-fans aus
es ist ein ganz normaler energy bringt
jetzt ein bvb fan ist oder so oder
generell fußball interessiert kann das
natürlich eine coole sache sagen einfach
nur um sicher zu gehen würde ich gern
ich glaube die höhe
ein liter dosen fast ich jetzt erstmal
gar nicht an das kann ich eigentlich
lukas schenkel luca ist bayern fan
der freut sich schon gerne ein liter spd
ändert liebling bekommst du ich
probier's mal die kleine andere dose vom
energy drink mit fc bayern münchen droht
bleibt dir gut klappt das könnte sein
weil bvb war gelb sie ist genauso geht
wie bvb und schmeckt wahrscheinlich auch
in ordnung
speck die bayern auf jeden fall
ich kann jetzt schon mal sagen bleibt
bis zum ende dran currywurst energy
drink zu leisten dann freue mich jetzt
mal die weiteren größen von dem von den
vereinen energiedrinks weg aber an sich
das ist doch schon mal krank oder eine
ein liter dose what the [ __ ] wenn ihr
euch eigentlich energy doe gekauft dann
bringen am besten nicht alleine
wer weiß noch
ehemals schlafen können so dass hier bei
mir übrig geblieben sind auch die
geister
dafür kommt als letzter zur seite und
berlin gehen wir mal aus ehe mit brad
pitt in weg und du bist weg weg bist du
noch lange nicht sagt mir erwe alter bis
11 das hier wird wenn ihr meine
hauptverfahren mögt dann könnt ihr mir
jetzt gerne ein abo da lassen oder ein
like oder
[Musik]
babbel ganz ist ein erfrischungsgetränk
mit dem geschmack von fruchtigen
kaugummi gibt ihrem kino
wie kommt man eigentlich auf bubblegum
stylen zutaten wasser zucker kohlensäure
säuerungsmittel zitronensäure oder
modifizierte stärke städtchen schwarzes
karottensaft konzentrat auch kates beste
auch zu leben ja also geht's auf jeden
fall aus sex up down to love streams
sehr nahe liegendes motto fand diese
leute wird das hier ist mein hatte ich
denke sachen zugeschickt dann bringe ich
das zeug weg und machte in 41 34 57 ab
19 25 cent fallen lassen in insgesamt 50
check den sound up what the [ __ ] läufe
war verspätet wie diese farbe dass
tatsächlich eine sache bubblegum
limonade
na dann immer mal hin und bubble gum
limonade hört denkt man so etwas
übertrieben süßes sonst kann nicht so
süß bitte eigentlich echt voll lecker
also ich muss sagen insgesamt
überraschend lecker aber ich hätte
gedacht künstlicher neben der kamerafrau
probiert um eine neuerliche aber richtig
cool
leute ich möchte euch jetzt bitten ganz
ganz aufmerksam zu sein
wie entscheiden jetzt dem vorvorletzten
kandidaten der ort getestet wird und es
ist was für ein zufall wie xxl american
colak wie verlief nicht so ausgebaut
aber ich hab ein bisschen schiss dass
wieder so sprudelt
jede menge druck ich muss sagen american
cola darunter stelle ich mir jetzt
erstmal dr pepper vor
ich war das also ich mag das eigentlich
jeweils die klassischen cola richtig
aber wie klassische polar und geschenk
man daheim erst mal dass ich so eine
lüfterlose aber
so ihre zum glück läuft normal cola
gäste zum wieder verschließen
american cup steht eine jukebox geht
sehr in die richtung von normaler cola
wird wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen
süße ist wir machen kurzen prozess
popkomm style erfrischungsgetränk mit
karamell geschmack ok jetzt wobei ein
popcorn und geht wieder den sound alles
riecht sehr karamatic aber auch der
gefahren wird meine freundin getötet der
kamera ist bisher noch nicht gemerkt hat
und immer so voll aufgeregt vor allem
darf ich dachte die flasche die probleme
aus welche farbe hat nur 17 monaten mit
den richtigen gäste es okay wie der
apfelsaft teil oder warum man schüttelt
naturtrüber apfelsaft ich mein freund es
mir ein bisschen gespannt ihre ist da
achtet das drin
anscheinend nicht aber dem abgang das
ohne popcorn note gabor ist es ja ein
bisschen säuerlich wieder fast so wie
das pinke acht leute jetzt legt ihr
einen track motion shop.com nase putzen
porsche arbeitet weiter geht erst mal
deinen rating leute dem moment ist auch
die alle gewartet habt wenn nicht darauf
gewartet hat man danke dass ihr trotzdem
ist jetzt auch ein abo salaten
leihkräften ab oder energy drink
currywurst ich muss sagen ich habe bock
drauf aber ich habe auch angst für
kinder und schwangere stillende frauen
nicht empfohlen ok liegt nicht daran
dass von currywurst bringt man einfach
weit energy drink ist so hier seht ihr
es noch mal auch ganz wichtig 100% vegan
dem körper wobei doch kann schluss einen
klar die leute trotzdem geschmack mögen
oh mein gott nein ich würde doch
eigentlich hab noch nicht gerochen aber
mir steigt gerade war für die nase
bricht eins zu eins die currywurst leute
all das macht mich gar nicht morgen wie
canvas was legal ist genauso richten ob
die bikerin also es ist eher das ist
unwahrscheinlich wie kraft nach köln
aussicht gestellten jetzt mal ein die
farbe rötlich leute entweder das wird so
geil oder es ist einfach schrecklich
ihr habt ihr es nur ein bisschen
rötlicher ed kohler schwarze karotte
sagt konzentrat ich habe keine ahnung
leute es ist eure wie kann sowas nur
kraft macht currywurst bieten egal die
warten wir die ganze probier's einfach
dass die currywurst die currywurst
wirken mit kohlensäure größer und so ein
bisschen sauer lied am anfang ich weiß
nicht ob ich das geil finden soll
also ich hab eigentlich nichts
einzuwenden gegen currywurst ich mit
etwas ganz gerne mal aber trinken so
komisch nicht eckig aber es ist einfach
komisch ich dazu sagen soll
verrückt es ist auf jeden fall verrückt
also currywurst ein energydrink körpers
fans auf jeden fall der steht
ich glaube ich bevorzuge dann doch einen
klassischen energie bringen aber
ausprobieren finde ich muss manchmal
auch du ja so leute ich hoffe mal dieses
wieder durchgefallen falls das der fall
ist fallt vierfach ausfall höher
vielleicht fragt ihr euch fragen ok dann
lasst euch gefallen hat gerne mal aber
da unbedingt empfehlungen was ich noch
machen kann austesten kann wie auch
immer in die kommentare so rathmann vom
heutigen video hier gibt es noch einen
abonnieren -button da könnt ihr euch
abonnieren werden das tun wollt solltet
ihr auf jeden fall
und hier oben gibt es veraltet video von
mir danke fürs zuschauen macht gut und
bis zum nächsten mal